there are nearly 10,000 of you in our
audience who are now subscribed to the
david pakman show subreddit where you
can discuss politics news and other
stuff I guess I would say with other
viewers and listeners you can find it at
david pakman.com slash reddit subscribe
for free and talk and chat with other
david pakman show viewers and listeners
a couple of interesting discussions that
I spotted this morning when I was
looking at the subreddit Sanders versus
Democrats Inc this is an example of what
I was talking about in the first segment
diversity Dan 79 posted quote I was
completely ready to vote for whoever won
the Democratic nomination this was
assuming a fair race because never did I
think the Democrats would meddle in the
elections again if the Democrats crown
in beto
or I guess he means Nancy Pelosi or
whomever I don't think I can vote for
them this is exactly what I was talking
about in the first segment talking about
the stop Bernie movement the Republicans
when it was Trump even if a lot of them
didn't want Trump they knew they had to
go and vote for Trump because otherwise
Hillary Clinton could win and she was
the so-called real enemy to the
Republican Party I'm not praising on the
merits or criticizing on the merits that
strategy I'm just telling you it's what
happened on the Republican side this
type of post is exactly what I'm talking
about as to why the Democrats can't run
a dirty campaign in this way because you
were going to see disaffected
progressive voters like diversity Dan 79
who made this post who say you know what
if it doesn't feel like a fair primary
and it feels like the Democratic Party
sort of crowns someone the candidate
anoints someone the candidate I might
vote third party or not vote at all and
that is exactly what I'm talking about
that we need to be careful of also from
the david pakman show subreddit a post
about what the fox news channel audience
thought of bernie and user colleague 3
says go check out the comments on the
upload on the fox news channel youtube
page there are virtually no negative
comments about bernie there are people
saying i
was wrong about him sure some of the
positive comments were made by us but I
have never ever seen anything like this
overall ratio on any news story Fox News
has ever posted not even close I think
that there was definitely some brigade
as it is called of the videos on YouTube
of the Bernie Sanders Fox News townhall
but I generally agree with you Bernie
Sanders has a long history of being very
good in front of hostile audiences and
by that I don't mean the the people
physically in the Town Hall room but the
broader Fox News Channel audience and he
knows how to talk to right-wingers in a
way that obviously he's not going to
convince everybody but some people start
to see the light of day so to speak and
you might remember during the townhall
Bernie didn't do too much just
criticizing of Donald Trump other than
calling him a pathological liar I
believe that that was calculated again
to appeal to the Fox News audience with
his ideas rather than just criticizing
Donald Trump join the discussion at
david pakman.com slash read it nearly
10,000 subscribers on the david pakman
show subreddit